these movie scenes had to be altered or
even axed completely just to allow their
films to make it by the sensors
and while we can't show you all of these
clips we can certainly tell you all
about them
2016 zootopia set a new march record for
animated movies when it opened to a 75
million dollar haul
walt disney animation's biggest opening
ever at the time
the film wound up scoring an incredible
98 on rotten tomatoes where critics
lauded it for its sumptuous animation
and inclusive message
however zootopia's message was delivered
in a far blunter fashion when it was
first conceived
the film we saw in cinemas was a
thoughtful commentary on racial
profiling with zootopia's minority
predator population discriminated
against by the fearful prey despite
their efforts to live harmoniously
the original script in which cynical fox
nick was the protagonist
not idealistic bunny cop judy contained
something called
taming parties in which predatory
animals were fitted with collars that
shocked them whenever they had a
carnivorous thought
co-director byron howard explained
during his blu-ray commentary
it stuck around a very very long time
because we found it
emotionally compelling compelling it may
have been but upon reflection disney
decided the shotcaller struck the wrong
court
2016's deadpool definitively proved once
and for all that there's a market for
r-rated superhero films
described as gleefully profaned by
rotten tomatoes the ryan reynolds
flick made over 780 million dollars at
the worldwide box office
with audiences going nuts for its no
holds barred take on the genre
there were some lines that they wouldn't
cross however as tim miller revealed at
an early screening
in particular there was a bar scene that
was too vulgar for even the r-rated
deadpool
t.j miller and ryan reynolds got
together and wrote a version of the
scene that we just said oh my god this
is too far
i mean there were so many people
offended it was just mean
and so i said no we don't have to do
that
tj miller who plays deadpool's best
friend weasel was also present at the
event and said the scene quote just got
more and more hateful the longer it went
paul verhoeven made two cuts to his
sci-fi classic robocop to bring it down
to an r
the offending scenes involved leading
man peter weller and kevin page who
played the young executive that gets
shot to ribbons during a botched
demonstration of the ed-209 police robot
paige told the hollywood reporter he
finally got the r in the last round of
submitting to the ratings board by
cutting four seconds
two seconds of me being shot on the
table and two seconds of the back of
peter weller's head coming off
weller who starred as alex murphy the
policeman who becomes robocop
had the more memorable of the scenes in
question his hand and arm are blown off
by shotgun blast before he takes a
bullet to the forehead
an elaborate model of weller was created
for the sequence which
originally showed the exit wound in
extreme detail
though this shot lasted less than a
second in the theatrical cut
matt stone and trey parker know all
about straddling the line between the r
and nc-17 ratings 2004's team america
world police had to be recut a total of
nine times before the mpaa granted it an
r
rating when the duo behind south park
first conceived their politically
charged all-puppet satire
the last thing they probably expected to
get pulled up on was the love scene
parker told the la times
it's something we all did as kids with
barbie and ken dolls
however the board didn't see it that way
finding much of the marionette action
too offensive
producer scott rudin said of the
prolonged battle to avoid the nc-17
rating there's nothing
we're asking for that hasn't appeared in
other r-rated movies
and our characters are made of wood and
have no genitalia
if the puppets did to each other what we
show them doing all they get is
splinters
wes craven's scream had to fight with
the mpaa to get an
r rating while the director refused to
alter the opening scene in which drew
barrymore's casey is stalked by the
killer
he agreed to remove the shot of her
boyfriend's steaming intestine spilling
out
there was one scene toward the end that
also had to be tweaked involving two
characters
stu and billy stabbing each other
repeatedly
craven told bloody disgusting almost the
entire third act had to be drastically
altered
you know the whole scene in the kitchen
with the boys stabbing each other to
establish the alibi
all of that when craven made scream 4 in
2011 he was surprised to find the
sensors in a far more lenient mood
on this film to my astonishment frankly
there were no cuts demanded
i guess if nothing else it's a great
example of how as a filmmaker you just
have no idea what the mpaa
is going to do deadpool pushed the
boundaries of the superhero movie
further than they'd ever been pushed
before
and deadpool 2 upped the ante when it
came to gleeful violence
but just like the first movie there were
some moments that went a little too far
and had to be cut speaking to cbr
screenwriter rhett reese revealed that
one of the film's post-credit scenes was
originally going to involve deadpool
traveling back in time and fulfilling a
long-held fantasy
that countless people have had over the
years originally it ended with deadpool
killing baby hitler
at the very very end of the credits we
had him going and killing an infant
version of hitler
we decided that was a little too harsh
not killing hitler
but killing a baby the scene was shot
and included in a test cut but audiences
didn't react as favorably as the
filmmakers originally envisioned
reese recounted to uprocks he's got the
crib and he's standing in the german
nursery and he's leaning over the crypt
to do it and there was kind of this
oh and we thought we don't want to leave
the crowd on an
oh so it ended up coming out i think we
both
no i don't have what it takes to do this
there are numerous examples of
politically incorrect moments in classic
hollywood movies that most certainly
wouldn't make it past censors today like
mickey rooney's portrayal of a japanese
man in breakfast at tiffany's or
disney's now infamous reconstruction era
movie song of the south
not many of them are as recent as 1985's
back to the future but at least director
robert zemeckis had the good sense to
cut a blatantly homophobic scene before
the movie hit theaters
the film's plot revolves around teenager
marty mcfly traveling back in time and
inadvertently becoming his own mother's
love interest
so it was always going to be a tight
rope walk for zemeckis
in the end he got the balance right i
don't know what it is
but when i kiss you it's like i'm
kissing
my brother but the deleted scene would
have been a huge problem had it remained
in the deleted scene marty tells emmett
doc brown that he's feeling a little
weird about the situation he's found
himself
in the doc responds by telling him to
quote take a few liberties with her
which is creepy enough as is but it's
marty's reply that really shocks as he
asks doc
what if i go back to the future and i
end up being gay
1985's the black cauldron almost sank
disney completely
with a production budget of 25 million
dollars which had reportedly ballooned
to 40 million dollars by the time it was
finished this loose adaptation of lloyd
alexander's award-winning fantasy series
the chronicles of pre-dane was the most
expensive animation
ever made at the time with walt himself
no longer around
new ceo michael eisner was eager to take
the company in a new direction and tap
into the dungeons and dragon loving teen
market though he came to regret his
decision
when his new team of young animators
brought the finished product to roy
disney walt's nephew apparently
experienced a quote
oh no feeling directors ted berman and
richard rich had gone way too dark for
disney
sensibilities new head of animation
jeffrey katzenberg cut a whopping 12
minutes from the movie
including a now notorious scene in which
the horned king's undead army kills two
henchmen in gruesome fashion
their skin is melted away leaving only
their skeletons behind
a former bad boy of british cinema late
director ken russell pushed his luck
with film sensors throughout his often
controversial career
the english director received an oscar
nomination for his 1969 film women in
love but recognition from the academy
didn't make him want to tone his style
down
quite the opposite in fact the ending
russell originally had planned for
1971's
the devils became the thing of legend
one scene the name of which
is so controversial we can't even say it
on youtube wasn't thought to actually
exist until a film critic found it
gathering dust in a warner brothers
vault
uk's channel 4 ended up showing the
infamous scene in which a group of
crazed nuns get
intimately familiar with the statue of
their lord and savior jesus christ
directly after the russell documentary
hell on earth the desecration and
resurrection of the devils
unsurprisingly the climatic scene had to
be cut from the devils before censors
would approve the film for release
as did a number of other offensive
moments there was originally a scene in
which vanessa redgrave's sister jean
puts a charred human bone somewhere that
she really shouldn't
and according to the guardian russell
was forced to edit out several other
shots to appease u.s sensors
todd phillips joker has no shortage of
extreme and arguably offensive moments
but there was at least one finished
scene that was too much for the
theatrical cut
speaking at the santa barbara
international film festival director
todd phillips revealed that he would
often allow leading man
joaquin phoenix plenty of room to
improvise which led to some pretty crazy
moments
phillips told esquire there were two or
three impromptu scenes we shot
one that is amazing in a bathtub but i
don't think we can actually include it
in an r-rated movie
and it's not because it was pornographic
it was just insane
phillips didn't explain why the axed
bathroom scene would have rubbed sensors
the wrong way
leaving fans to guess just what he
filmed that day
one scene that did make the final cut
saw arthur fleck giving his frail mother
a bath
did this scene have originally been
longer or was phillips talking about a
different bathtub scene altogether
sadly we'll probably never find out as
phillips told collider
i hate deleted scenes they're deleted
for a reason the movie that exists is
exactly the movie i want it to be and i
will never show a deleted scene
disney plus users are met with a warning
about quote outdated cultural depictions
when they select some of the studio's
older animated offerings
fantasia included released in 1940
disney's third feature film consists of
eight
individual segments one of which was
considered controversial from the
beginning
the female centaurs in the fifth segment
the pastoral symphony were originally
drawn bare-breasted but the nudity
ultimately fell outside of motion
picture production code guidelines
meaning they had to be redrawn
the centaur's breasts were covered up
but remarkably nobody saw a problem with
the racist insensitive depictions of
black centaurs in the greek mythology
inspired segment
in the original version the pastoral
symphony featured two dark-skinned
female centaurs named otika and
sunflower
both of whom serve light-skinned
characters otiko rolls the red carpet
out for bacchus the god of wine while
sunflowers shone polishing the hose of a
white female centaur
the studio started editing the
characters out of the film in 1969
disney editor john carneken who removed
many of these shots for the 1991 vhs
release told entertainment weekly
it's sort of appalling to me that these
stereotypes were ever put in
in the year 2000 disney released a
so-called uncut version of fantasia to
mark the film's 60th anniversary
keeping otika and sunflower out of sight
with subtle pans and zooms
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie moments are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]